okay guys massive massive news and that
is I've decided just last night I
decided I'm gonna do the financial
freedom challenge all over again in
other words I'm going to become
financially free again I'm going to
start again but this time in a different
country because I'm so tired of hearing
excuses from people overseas
[Music]
on the 18th of March ye just like three
weeks away from today I'm gonna rock up
to an airport and I'm gonna go to a
random country and do the financial
freedom challenge again I might end up
in Australia Singapore America somewhere
in Europe sweet Switzerland Sweden
Holland I have no idea where I'm gonna
go but what I want you to do is I want
you to comment below tell me where you
want me to go tell me maybe your local
country and I'll go and I'm gonna do
make some money in property with no
money starting from scratch I'm so
excited I'm so pumped I'm a little bit
terrified but I'm prepared to do this
put my neck on the line once again just
to demonstrate that the strategies that
I teach making money in property it's
not just uk-based people ask me all the
time does this work in America does this
work in Australia does this work in
Holland the answer is yes it does it
does work in your country there are some
small changes there's not every strategy
that I teach in the UK not every
strategy will work in every country but
the principles are the same the ability
to be able to make money from scratch
through property is the same I say that
but I'm about to put it to the test I'm
gonna put my neck on the line so comment
below with your country I've also got a
Facebook group which is the property
investors with Samuel Leeds Facebook
group I'm gonna be posting updates on
the Facebook group so join that in the
description below on this video is going
to be a link to the Facebook group you
can join that for free maybe I'm crazy I
tell you what though it's gonna be a lot
of fun and because I'm already
financially for it half the time I can
start doing this kind of thing pushing
the boundaries learning myself and
demonstrating to you guys that this is
possible but absolutely anybody no
matter where you are in the world peace
out subscribe share this video I'll see
you next time
[Music]